- If you are a young business graduate
and are thinking about what
the first job should be
that you should accept
fresh out of university
and if you are looking to be successful
in the business world in the long-term,
I believe my humble opinion
that joining consulting firm
is probably the best career
move that you can take.
But before we jump into that,
I have some great news to share.
Look at this baby that
arrived over the weekend.
Let's take a few moments
to celebrate this baby.
Hi guys, how's it going?
Hope you're all having a great day.
So this is not the first time
I'm filming with my new equipment.
So I got myself in a new
camera, a new microphone
and a new lens over the weekend.
So hope you see some kind of difference.
The Easter holidays for me are a great way
to reconnect with myself,
with my family and my friends.
Hope you also had a similar
great experience at home.
I know the current times are difficult.
It is going to be a very
special Easter holiday
for most of us.
In the last days I tried
to work on a few things,
I set up my Instagram
channel for you again,
I'm currently posting several
pieces of content there
every single day.
So let me know if you
have any feedback for me,
I would highly appreciate your views.
But now back to the studio
and welcome once again
to another coffee break
with Firm Learning.
For those of you who are regular watchers
and subscribers of this channel,
thank you so much for your time.
And for those of you
watched the first time
first of all, welcome my name is Heinrich
and here on Firm Learning
I want to help you become successful
in the first years of your career.
This video is all about consulting.
It covers what I believe
it is extremely valuable
and helpful to start
off your business career
as a consultant even though
if you actually wanna do
something else in the long-term
and becoming a consultant is not something
that you plan to do forever.
So if you take any value
out of this video at all,
please press the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe and
hit the notification bell
to stay up-to-date and receive
all the regular content
that I'm putting out there for you.
At the moment,
I'm releasing at least one
video every single Saturday.
And in many weeks,
there's going even to be a
second video for you guys.
So if you are graduating
from university soon,
you will likely ask yourself the question,
what should be the first job?
What should be the first
role that I should take
when I now start my career?
What is the wise career move,
the first thing that I should start,
the first job that I should take?
And when I graduated
from my master program
at the London School of Economics,
I asked myself the same question.
And in my mind I bid in a stylized way,
I saw four options that you can
take as a business graduate.
You can either go into consulting,
you can go into banking,
you can work in industry or
you can start a start-up.
Of course, this is grossly simplified,
but if you break it down,
this is pretty much what you can do.
These are your options.
So let's briefly go over the
startup and the banking choice.
I believe that these two choices
are really specific choices
to people who's passion it is
to do exactly these things.
So if you want to do a start up,
if you want to become an entrepreneur,
you're probably not thinking
about whether you should
take on an industry job.
Most entrepreneurs I know they
just have it in your blood.
If you wanna start a business,
if you wanna become an
entrepreneur, do a start up,
there's no other options for you.
And in this video, I'm not going in to try
to convince you to do something else.
I believe doing a startup is amazing.
If this is how you're taking,
if this is what your
passion is, then go for it.
I fully have your back
go all in, this is great.
And even though on the one
side it's completely different,
on the other side, kind of
similar to that is banking.
From my experience,
there's a special type
of business students,
a special type of people and personalities
who wanna go down the banking path
and even though banking now is
probably a bit less relevant
to many people than it
was roughly 10 years ago
when I graduated from my master program,
banking still can be a
great career option for you.
I have many friends who
work in investment banks,
or private equity, or similar role
and they very much enjoy it.
And of course, it can be highly attractive
from a financial side as well.
So startup and banking for this video,
I wanna a bit put aside,
because I believe while these
are very viable options,
either you wanna do it or you don't.
So the more interesting question
where I see people struggle with,
is for the other two sectors,
it's for consulting or for an industry.
So if you are a young graduate,
usually should you rather
pick the consulting
or the industry path?
And just to be clear here on
terminology with industry,
I mean the more regular
standard business companies
across all industries.
So let it be automotive, let
it be advanced industries,
let it be retail, pharma, oil
and gas, telecommunication.
All of this is what I summarized
under the industry label.
So how does a typical industry starter job
compare to a typical
consulting starter job,
and I know now that in the comments
people will write that of course
there's a huge diversity of jobs,
both in industry and consulting,
and yes, you're completely right.
But I just try to generalize here a bit
because I do believe that many
of the roles within industry
and that within the consulting
are pretty similar and comparable.
So in a typical industry role,
you start in one department.
So you will either base
the business development,
or maybe managerial accounting,
or production, or sales,
and then you work in
that team for a time span
of several years.
You will be dedicated to fixed team,
you will have your one supervisor,
and then the game for you is pretty much
growing into this role really
becoming a part of the team,
and then becoming a part of
the day-to-day operations
of the business
and trying to really move
the business forward,
making an impact in the business
and every day that you worked out.
So how does this compare to consulting?
Well, and if I talk about consulting
I of course, especially mean
the large strategy consulting firms
like BCG, Bain or McKinsey,
where you are usually in a setting
where you work in a very small team
of two, three or four people
on the ground for one client.
A typical project will
go on for a duration
of two to five months,
and then project for
project you will usually
change functions, change
industries, change clients
and then over the course of several years
get exposure to many of
these different situations.
By then over time after your
two, three, four years down
into your consulting role,
if you will specialize
more and more generally
on one industry to then
really become an expert
in one of these fields.
So while no doubt there
are disadvantages as well
when working in consulting.
In this video, I will argue
that I believe for most people out there,
who are a young business graduate
and are looking to make a mark
in the business world in the long-term.
For most of these people,
it is the best choice to start
in a strategy consulting firm
such as McKinsey, Bain or BCG,
if you're looking for the first job
that you can take in your career.
So let me tell you five strong reasons
why I believe that this is the case.
So the first reason that I
see is the size of a team.
If you work at McKinsey,
or BCG, typical team size
is two to four people.
On a typical project there
will be one project lead
on the ground,
and then to associate
supporting him at the client.
If you start as a consultant,
you will from the first week on
be staffed on a client project
and will become one of these three members
of your project team.
Then usually what happens
is that the project lead
will divide the project
into different work streams.
So pretty much packages of
work that need to be done
and then distribute them
to all the team members,
so each of the associates and
the project leader himself
will have a certain set of tasks
that he is responsible for.
So imagine there's a company
with two business units
and as a BCG consultant,
now you are being asked
to identify cost improvement potentials
for these two business units.
So in such a project,
what will typically happen is
that there are two associates,
each associate is responsible
for one of the business units
and then there's the project lead
who will take care of some
maybe minor tasks left and right
and of course, is responsible
for the overall quality
of the output of the team.
And what you will quickly realize
as such a young consultant
is that from early on, you will be alone,
sitting in meetings with senior clients
of this business units with
pretty much work on yourself,
pushing forward the topics
that you need to do.
And if you for whatever
reason failed to do that,
if you're not able to do that,
the whole team will struggle a lot,
because obviously the other associate
cannot also take care of
your whole business unit,
because he is already highly utilized
with the work that he is doing.
And the project lead of
course, has many things to do,
and yes, for sure he will
help you and cover you
but he cannot pick up all
the slack of your work,
if you're not doing it.
So what this means is that from early on,
you would be a critical
fundamental part of the team
and the whole team will
automatically rely on you
getting the job done and doing good work.
And trust me that this is vastly different
from working in an industry,
where usually you are part of a big team,
you have 10, 20, 30, 40 other people
working in your department.
And then as a new joiner
maybe they transfer a
few minor tasks to you
that you then can work on.
But in most of these roles
it's not a real serious problem
if you for whatever reasons struggle
because there will be other
people who can help you out.
If it's really not working out,
they can likely also completely
cover all your tasks,
especially in the beginning,
to give you some time to
really grow into your role
in the first year or so.
In consulting it's different.
You will be expected to grow
into your role within weeks.
And this very much feels
like being thrown into the cold water
and it can sometimes be quite
a frightening experience
for a new business joiner,
but this is exactly why the learning curve
in consulting is so high,
and why you will learn such
a tremendous amount of things
after working for consulting
within only one or two years.
It is a learning experience
that is pretty much unparalleled
in almost all interesting jobs out there.
Reason number two is the
exposure that you get
to many different leadership styles.
And this is something that I believe
many people significantly undervalue
when they are thinking about
joining a job in an industry.
'Cause in industry you're
part of a fixed team.
And this means that your
supervisor or your team lead
will usually be constant,
maybe fixed for a long period of time.
So if you're there for three
years, four years, five years,
maybe even longer,
it could be the case that all the time
you work with and for
the very same team lead
or team manager the whole time,
and why this of course has some advantages
and there can be a deep
mentoring relationship
coming out of that,
the big downside is that you get exposure
to only this one leadership style.
And this could not be more different
than what you will experience
when you work in consulting.
In consulting every two to five months
you will work on a new project
and this usually involves
that you will work with
a new project lead.
And but of course, it is true
that there is a certain
homogeneous culture
in a consulting firm like BCG or McKinsey,
the truth is also that still
the leadership styles of the people
are sometimes vastly different.
The way your project lead
will handle difficult client meetings,
the way your project lead will react
when the more senior partner
of the consulting firm
pushes the project team
in a certain direction.
But if he believes that this
is not the right direction,
how he will push back
to the senior leadership
will be vastly different
among the different people.
How we handles the team.
How he motivates you.
How he interacts with you.
All of this will be vastly
different from person to person.
And as a consultant sitting
on the receiving end
of this internal leadership that you get,
this gives you the opportunity
to self reflect a lot.
Because this is as if there
would be lots of experiments
happening just in front of you.
You can watch all these
project leads of you
trying out different things,
different styles and
seeing what is working,
what is not working.
And of course, you will
frequently see these people
do certain things, and the
end you will tell yourself,
well, probably I would
have handled this situation
a different way.
Probably the way that he handled this
didn't really work out that well,
he should probably have
done something else.
And the fact that you see
all these different styles
in the short amount of time
really enables you to ask yourself,
what is the type of leader
that you want to become?
What is the leadership style
that you want to adopt?
And the exposure to all
these different styles
from my experience is extremely valuable.
And this is something that
you would just not get at all
if you work in an industry
or in another position,
where your boss, your supervisor
will be the very same person
for a long amount of time.
And this now leads me
to reason number three,
and this is that an industry
often highly dependent
on a small amount of people,
and especially your direct supervisor.
How your work is evaluated?
Whether you're considered as
a strong performer or not?
What your internal
performance rating would be?
An industry will very much
depend on your direct supervisor.
And of course, this can be a big plus
if you happen to get along
really well with a person
but on the other hand side,
if you do not get along
with a person really well
this can become a huge problem for you.
Because pretty much the
only choice that you have
is either transitional
roles within the company,
which is often easier said than done,
or change your job to a
completely new employer,
which of course, is not
something that you often wanna do
if you're just within the first
year or so of your career.
So if you compare that now to consulting,
in consulting you usually change the teams
every couple of months.
And this means that if you happen to work
with a project lead for whom you
and probably then also
the project lead realizes
that this isn't really a good fit.
In a few months, he would change
the team, it's a new game.
There will be a new
person who can work with
then over time, you
will have a good network
of project leads, of partners
with whom you enjoy working,
and then hopefully also on the other side,
they will enjoy working with you.
And then you can actively try
to seek out working together
with these people more and more.
They then appreciate you as well,
they of course will be more
than happy to work with you
again and again.
And by this you can really
build your own community.
You can build your own firm
within the consulting firm.
And in consulting this is then
how mutually beneficial
mentorship relationships
can be built.
Because you want to work again
with these project leads,
the partners want to work again with you
because they know that you
are a rockstar, you are loyal,
you will do great work for
them on their projects.
This is really completely different
to how it works in industry.
Reason number four is the
sheer amount of experiences
that you get from working
for a large strategy consulting
firm, like McKinsey or BCG
when you start out with your career.
During my six years at McKinsey,
I've been involved in lots of projects
covering all types of
industries and functions.
I have been involved in large M&As
so mergers and acquisitions transactions.
I've been working on major cost
and revenue transformations
of large blue chip companies.
I've worked on all kinds of countries
within and outside of Europe.
I work together with buying departments
helping them improve their
direct and indirect spend.
I developed new sales strategies
for large chemicals companies.
You're pricing structures
for retail companies.
I evaluated the CAPEX pipeline
for automotive suppliers.
And many, many, many more things.
I would argue that it's just impossible
to get that amount of
experience in that little time
if you work in pretty much
any regular industry role.
And last but not least is the exposure
to C-level management of
large blue chip companies
that you get early on.
On many projects you will work
closely together with CEOs,
CFOs of large companies.
You would work together
with business unit heads
with really senior level
management of the companies.
These are people that if you
work in a normal department,
in a normal industry role
you might never even speak to face-to-face
in the first years of your career.
And to the contrary, as a
McKinsey or BCG consultant,
you sit together in a room with them
and work together with
them on the most pressing
top of mind issues that
these C-level executives
have in their head.
And they seek your
expertise, they respect you
and they closely work together with you
to solve these high priority
issues of their companies.
This is just unparalleled,
this will not be possible
in most industry roles.
So looking at these five reasons,
I honestly believe that
pretty much independent
of what you wanna do in the long-term,
you will benefit from having
worked a couple of years
in a large strategy consulting firm,
such as McKinsey or BCG.
But also do not get me wrong,
consulting is not perfect.
It's not a fairy tale.
It's no lala land that you work in
and everything is just great and amazing.
There are some significant downsides
of working in consulting as well.
And here I'm not even talking
about work life balance,
but rather specific learnings
that I believe are crucial
and absolutely needed
for you to be successful in the long-term,
but which you will not
develop at all in consulting.
So this could actually be another video
me talking about what the things are
that you will for sure
not learn in consulting.
So if this is something
that would interest you,
please let me know below in the comments.
And I'll likely make another video on that
in the couple of weeks.
But just because there are some things
which you will not learn in consulting,
I also believe that it is important
that after a couple of years,
you're thinking about making a transition
and going into more
operational, more hands on role,
your development path of
becoming a go to waivers
business professional of
becoming a good general manager
would just not be completed.
If you're just working
in consulting you need
the small operational line
management experience this way.
So what is your thinking on all of this?
Let me know your opinion
below in the comments.
Probably some of you
thinking that I'm wrong
and consulting is not
the best role to start
as a young business professionals.
So very happy to have an
open conversation here.
Let me know what your thoughts are,
and I will give you an
answer below in the comments.
And again, if you took any
value out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also hit the subscribe button,
as well as activate the notification bell
to stay informed and up-to-date
on all the future content
I've planned for you.
I will release at least one
video every single Saturday.
And as some of you have already seen,
I'm pretty active on Instagram.
I'm posting new content
every single day there.
So follow me on my Instagram
handle FirmLearning
to stay posted.
Thank you for watching everybody,
stay safe and keep learning.
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning.